seconds did you ever think you
make Victory I
know
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv vales contagious
this world are entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm I'm the
[Music]
one okay episode 337 we figured this has
been a wild week uh I called the boys
yesterday I said guys I think we need a
live podcast we can't wait till Tuesday
there's a lot of stories going on Rob
made it happen we got Adam Vinnie in the
house Tom's in the house the crews in
the back and we got a bunch of stories
to go through with you um one thing I
will tell you for I had a call with my
uh penguin uh uh what do you call it uh
uh yesterday they said look the numbers
are looking good it's really close to
potentially next week getting some news
so if some of you guys haven't yet
bought the book choose your enemies WIS
day I I can't tell you how many people
are calling me telling me after they
finish the book how they're feeling the
stories in it how it's driving them
moving it if you got big plans for
2024 you can go ahead and place the
order on Amazon uh Barnes & Noble all
over the place should have it many
places are sold out but some places they
still have it and I would suggest
ordering the hard cover as well as the
audiobook if you haven't yet ordered it
Rob if you want to put that in the chat
in the description having said that
here's the stories we got today vivec
this man told Nikki Haley and Chris
Christie telling Chris Christie to his
face get the hell out of here you have
to see that then Larry think is sitting
there saying dude why are you calling me
out why is it that you guys are talking
about Black Rock more than you're
talking about inflation we'll talk about
him the debate was the least viewed
debate apparently in a long time only
four million people watched the debate
then hanor Biden the details came out
about how much money he was spending on
hookers um it's it's got to this has got
to be like a record-breaking the kind of
money he was spending Adam second place
he would Adam Adam's right behind but
the distance between first and second
was wild Trump appointed judge will be
seeing Hunter Bon's tax evasion case
California budget deficit swells to
record 68 billion as tax revenue Falls
we'll talk about that Megan kelly didn't
have good things to say about Trump
Megan Kelly said Trump has lost multiple
steps mentally uh now whether she's
poking a bear or doing what she's doing
it is what it is to have a very unique
relationship together you should see
what happened
with Tom these are what these are the
presidents of Penn Harvard and MIT right
getting called out publicly and the
exchange and what they couldn't admit to
which led to one donor from Penn to take
a hundred million doll of donation off
the table mean that's a lot of money
guys a $100 million off the table and
billionaire and Harvard grad Bill akman
suggest Harvard president was a Dei pick
there's a bunch of stories there that's
very interesting Elon Musk just did a uh
um he's running a poll right now whether
he should reinstate Alex Jones or not
we'll give you an update on that Elon
Musk calls for Disney SE I don't think
we've reacted to it we'll talk about
that a little bit luxury stores are
bursting with unsold stuff if you want
to buy a watch right now watch inventory
is high those luxury watches that were
50 Grand that were selling for 100 Grand
or that were 10 grand they were selling
for 20 today's the complete opposite go
to Rolex store 3 years ago there was no
Rolex watches go to Rox store today it's
filled with watches which means if
you're a buyer may not be a bad season
and last but not least or if you're a
looter in California just that is right
loot in time for col I never even
thought about that by the way for some
of you that are literal people Tom is
literally joking with you just so you
know that never seeing family or friends
can can lead to an early death oh sh
what a what a warming story we have
there okay so let's get right into the
first one here Rob if you want to pull
up vivec and I say we do Vic and put the
full no put the one with Nikki Haley he
starts off there and then we'll go with
the Vic and Chris Christie wh watch this
right here what he does to Nikki Haley
Clinic yeah I mean it's just the look on
her face and now remember guys here's
what you need to know no matter what
anybody says a lot of billionaires a lot
of establishment money a lot of
establishment Republicans are choosing
Nikki Haley as their candidate you know
why they want her as their candidate
okay so a lot of that money was
initially was this s is going now to
pivoted her so but watch what vivec does
to here Rob go ahead and play this clip
here I so foreign policy experience is
not the same as foreign policy wisdom I
want everybody at home to note that I
was the first person to say we need a
reasonable peace deal in Ukraine now a
lot of the neocons are quietly coming
along to that position with the
exceptions of Nikki Haley and Joe Biden
who still support this what I believe is
pointless war in Ukraine and I think
those with foreign policy experience one
thing that Joe Biden and Nikki Haley
have in common is that neither of them
could even state for you three provinces
in eastern Ukraine that they want to
send our troops to actually fight for
look at that this is what I want people
to understand these people have no idea
what the hell the names of those provin
are want our sons and daughters and our
troops and our military equipment to go
fight it so reject this myth that
they've been selling you that somebody
had a cup of coffee stint at the UN and
then makes 8 million bucks after has
real foreign policy experience it takes
an outsider to see this through look at
the blank expression she doesn't know
the names of the pro that she wants to
actually fight for and there's her puet
master
right the donors right there that are
playing like the puet I love him P did
she respond to that she couldn't say
anything by the way if she knew the
providences SP she would have owned him
instead blank look she did not know she
had no idea Tom what do you think about
when he see this Tom um I think vivec is
saying and demonstrating what the
American voter wants to see which is
some guts and some truth and he's got
facts he's backing up but he's wrapping
it up into an an accusation um my
daughter saw this and I said what did
you think of a she said well they're
probably going to say he's a jerk but he
was being very clear and this is a
17-year-old girl she you know how we all
feel in our house but the point is I
think that's what America's feeling
America's feeling dude you're right and
the establishment you know was referring
to him as a jerk saying that he's a
petulent little brat and and trying to
but look how they're trying to put
labels on what was a guy that that made
a very strong clear comment and you saw
the stunned look they were all sitting
there looking back as Dan sanis took two
steps back in his heels and put his
hands in his pocket did you see that he
wanted no part of that he was physically
showing all right you can just yell
right across the front of my Podium and
just leave me be it's funny you're
saying that there's a video that's going
viral from The Daily Show if you got
that Rob I don't a bunch of guys sent me
this I didn't I thought I didn't even
know what this was and then apparently
this was AI Rob go
ahead Rob we can't hear it Rob we can't
hear it 5' 11 you're go go back go back
yeah
remember Ron you are normal you are not
weird you are 5 foot1 your suit is soft
and your shoes are grown up big boy
shoes that's it pretend you're listening
to music Human music good check the
phone normal
style activate conversation mode hello
you're busy okay love you
bye come on Ron be normal you are not a
bobblehead with a dry mouth you are a
big boy with a wet mouth activate head
turn activate toothless smile good very
good oh my God brilliant activate hand
gesture uh good that's better remember
you are a rondy santis you aren't just
normal you're also totally not
weird let me respond to this by the way
the Daily Show has not been funny since
John Stewart left what was his name
Trevor uh Trevor Noah oh my God absolute
hor if you ever sees this clip no
offense you're a great guy see me I love
to have a beer with you buddy least
funniest host I've ever seen oh Trevor
Noah what do you mean I didn't even know
he did stand up not funny whatever so
woke so bought and sold and paid for by
the left there's one person that's super
funny on The Daily Show Jordan Clapper
you ever see his stuff that he goes out
there does those show of course you
don't but this right here was probably
the funniest clip I've seen produced by
The Daily Show in years oh yeah years
yeah in years years I I would respect R
like at this point at this point cuz he
know Ronda santz knows people are
talking if I was him I would open the
debate like you know what Pat Patrick M
Davis talk crap every I would kick the
boots and just get right down to here
I'm like what what yeah I'm sure but hey
Co I kicked ass during Co I would do
that and guess what he would Skyrock it
he just doesn't have it dude I've spoken
with multiple people that are are in his
orbit yeah he's a policy wonk super
smart he just don't have that Riz that
fact he just doesn't have it well you
talk about multiple people in his orbit
but you and Pat were there along with a
small group of media that was invited to
the governor's mansion during the
formative weeks of the development of
the campaign couple weeks before Ann you
saw it live it's not just people in his
orbit you talked to you guys saw it live
it just stiff and uninitiated person Pat
I'll I'll I'll let you respond to this
but typically this is just unsolicited
advice to the governor respect you I
would vote for you a million times out
of a over Gavin Newsome somehow Gavin
Nome won that debate when all the facts
were on Sanders's side but when you get
into a room and it's a how many people
were in that room Pat that the
governor's mansion 18 to 20 people just
hot tip for anybody starting a speech
don't just go straight into facts just
be like guys so happy you guys are all
here how you doing buddy what's good to
see you man all right cool with that
being said we're gonna have a great
conversation today blah blah blah blah
blah now let's get started you don't
start a speech with hi guys the GDP of
Florida and then the people in Publics
and the teachers union it's like dude
like just give a quick little intro say
hi it was a little uh so so little too
at this point who do you think was the
person I know we talked about it once
who was the person that looked at Ronda
Sanders said listen president you can do
it do you think it was his wife or you
think it was somebody that was like like
on the one person who was it Jesus no it
wasn't Jesus who do you think it was Tom
honestly I I think his wife has
aspirations and is managing his career
with him in Partnership and she pushed
him too early what do you think if you
had to guess I I think it's himself I
think it's himself and then his wife uh
encouraging and a bunch of other people
but you have to you you the the
filtering to know what flattery is it's
such a hard filter to have most people
don't have it because you you want to
hear somebody say things about you that
it's like imagine somebody comes to Tom
and says hey you know without without
you Pat would never do anything you know
that right I don't think Pat gives you
enough credit and Tom buys that flattery
yeah in that moment Tom May
independently be like I kind of agree
you're right okay and say I'm not part
of that discussion and he bu's into that
say somebody comes to me and says hey
Pat just so you know you know without
you Tom wouldn't be anything right
because you're giving to the eyeball and
I'm like well yeah I'm giving him the
eyeball you you can't fall for it it's a
trap right so somebody came in and the
biggest thing that hurt his chance of
being a president they told him you can
do it without Trump they told him you
need to go after him and that decreased
his chances of ever being a president by
a big margin listen this doesn't mean he
can't be a president he can a lot of
weird things can still happen today but
let's just say say Trump's out of the
equation say Trump's out of the equation
yeah flat out say Trump's not going to
be running something happens he can't
run where's the magav vot going to be
going to the santis or to VC V to VC of
course so that that even that he's not
going to get so he he he told the the
magga crowd look you know you're
delusional in a way he didn't say that
but I'm saying is the position he took
but this is more about Nikki Haley right
now guys Nikki Haley and Chris Christie
the way they set this up because if it's
five they've always put the santis right
in the middle they've always had the
santis if it's odd the number one guy is
in the middle and vivec went from all
the way in the outside and he's worked
himself right next to it's like in Mr
Olympia what happens is when they're
doing shows the best bodybuilder
physians in the middle and let's just
say you're on the outside and last year
nobody looked at you as a competitor the
next thing you're posing next to the
main competitor they're like oh [__]
this guy could be taking it yeah and
that when Jay Cutler beat Ronnie or
Ronnie beat all these other guys it kind
of works like that so we've ex worked
them but watch the way they positioned
it they put the two establishment guys
right next to each other Chris Christie
and Nikki Haley they put the one that is
somewhat a hybrid between establishment
and non-establishment which is who the
santis he's a hybrid and they put the
non-establishment all the way to his
Corner which is who Vic now Rob do me a
favor go to the longer clip with him and
chrisy where he dismantles Christy and
what he tells him is this the one that
you have or go and play this clip let's
see if the audio please if not just back
it up I think we okay perfect that's
fine watch this we learn three things
let we learned three things right there
first of all Chris Christie also doesn't
know what provinces in eastern Ukraine
he actually want us to fight for look at
his face Chris your version of foreign
policy experience was closing a bridge
from New Jersey to New York so do
everybody a favor just walk yourself off
that stage enjoy a nice meal and get the
hell out of this race hisory such aast
actually send your sons and daughters to
go die in somebody else's War you better
excuse me Chris I'm speaking and I'm not
done yet
and we're going to be done so listen up
to this is if these people want to send
your sons and daughters to go die in
ukra they've been arguing for it for a
year $200 billion of our taxpayer money
sent over neither of them could even
name for you the provinces that they
actually want to protect and this is the
people who have been touting their soall
foreign policy experience it is
intellectual fraud these people are
lying to you the same people who told
you about weapons and mass destruction
in Iraq to justify that Invasion didn't
know the first thing about it yet they
sent thousands of our sons and daughters
to go die the same people who told you
the same in Afghanistan where the
Taliban is still in charge 20 years
later 7 trillion of our national debt
due to these toxic neocons you can put
lipstick on a Dick Cheney it is still a
fascist
neocon thank you Mr all over again in
this thank you Mr ramaswami can I tell
you the best thing that ever happened to
the back the best thing that ever
happened to buling was when we were in
play at the Reagan Library for that
second debate M and he tried to play Mr
Nice Guy you remember that of course Hey
cuz the first debate he came out there
guns blazing the second debate he
realized oh [__] these guys are all here
to attack me and he was like no can't we
all get along he SE counsel he went back
to the drawing board he looked in the
mirror and he just said f you I'm going
for it and he CH his en and he's just
been fired up ever since I think this is
him I think this is the natural VC he
has facts that he puts together along
with the assertive argument with the
with the uh you know kind of the nail on
the head you know go have a nice meal
get the hell stage right my line but
that is Adam's line no it's but I think
it's correct I think you're seeing the
real VC the real VC has facts and he
argues with facts but he also wraps them
with a punch and that's what I think
this is the real guy we saw him at
intermission we walked up on stage and
talked to him for about one minute you
know no security came up and everything
and we encouraged him and everything but
during the intermission you could feel
the fire in the fight but he didn't show
it when it was live during the debate
Valley but I think I think a I mean I
think that that's him but something he
went into another gear because it wasn't
this this like pointed going at him I
mean d the guy's brilliant but something
something shifted in fifth gear where
it's like now it's no holes barred and
I'm putting everybody on blast which is
back by fact and and you could dude if
you have the facts and now you're
putting them and you're questioning them
to see if they know it and they don't
you win BR he won that by by by 10
length just look what he did in the
third debate when we were all there in
Miami the second debate in La he tried
to play Mr Nice Guy flopped yeah third
debate he walks up on stage he basically
said the old office space thing [__] you
[__] you [__] you [__] you you're cool
all right let's roll Ronald McDaniel
please step down Kristen Welker you're
bought and paid for why don't you
apologize for this fu f you f you f you
and now and like what now and everyone's
like holy [__] this guy means business
by by the way you see that the way vivec
is pushing the the the first thing I do
after the debate was over with the next
day I go type in GOP debate winners Rob
just go type in GOP debate winners can't
wait for this and look what everybody
said winners and losers okay just pick a
story go to any one of them okay go to
perfect go to that one fourth I'm guar
it says three winners one losers
I guarantee you the one loser they put
as vvec watch this go all the way down
go all the way down so winners haly and
chrisy winners halien winner Christy the
Haley
Christie the man that's been losing in
the polls is somehow a winner keep going
keep going let's see what they got here
what's this one far conspiracy theorist
as a winner okay that's not a winner
that's not a winner though it's sort of
like a humble brag yeah that is not a
winner you're fat but you look good
today yeah January 6 and all this stuff
cuz they still that to be an
Insurrection okay but go to the next one
that's not called the winner that's
that's a loser small government
conservative okay go to the next one how
they put the word small all right winner
Donald Trump okay let's go to the next
site go pick a different site go to uh
uh let's see what the uh what is it okay
go to that one let's see what the hill
says and then go to New York Times okay
so here's the hill winners and losers wi
winner Ronda santis look how confusing
this is so Ronda santz the winner keep
going he was the loser in the last no he
yeah that's right they're saying he's
the winner okay Donald Trump winner okay
keep going and then who else you got
mixed Nikki Haley She's mixed okay uh
and then who else we got here Chris
Christie mixed and then go all the way
to the bottom and guess who's the loser
let's actually read this the number of
Voters holding an unfavor opinion R
ramaswami has sharpened in poll recent
summer he likely spiked those numbers
Wednesday condescending line of attack
against Haley suggesting at least
metaphorically that she didn't tell the
difference between United States and
Israel even Drew chrisy to come to A's
defense described a piece of paper
alleging corruption was far to obviously
a pre-planned gimmick ramaswami also
continued his tendency to pump oxygen
into conspiracy theories while relieving
himself a silver deniability the 2020
election was indeed stolen by big Tech
he's not lying Twitter didn't post the
story a fact he said a phrasing that
seemed designed to appeal to magga so
again go to next one so so far we let's
look at what New York Times says we
looked at the hill and we looked at Vox
so here he's a clown Haley Haley Haley
Chris Christie is first place look at
that no way look at that and look who's
last VC is last place this is New York
Times scre scroll down a little bit what
does it say below that he's a clown and
not even one of the good ones winners
and losers so I'm assuming that's
probably a quote from Christy to Vive
keep going
lower so they give it to christe
Christie there's no way yeah oh my gosh
that he there's no like and and then
they wonder why nobody's watching them
but but this what you can't say that how
many subscribers go go type in New York
Times number of subscribers New York
Times New York Times subscribers okay
how many millions do they have 10
million what do you mean nobody is
listening but I mean listening but
believing it no of course they're
believing it they're paying M suful
digital publication they are the people
are watching so how many people watched
the debate a lot of people didn't
they're going to sit there and say Chris
Christy crushed it and this vet guy's a
loser this is what they're doing to
people that they're and by the way play
Van Jones what van Jones said okay go if
you got watch this clip here look at his
reaction this is right after watch this
mug condescending way that he just
spewed his poison out is very very
dangerous because he won't stop Trump
but he's going to outlive Trump by about
50 years and you're watching the rise of
an American demagog that is a very very
despicable person
and I was I was shaking listening to him
talk because a lot of people don't know
that is one step away from NY propaganda
coming out of his
mouth I would love to know the comment
that he's talking about because van
Jones is Not an he's not an I would like
to know the comment that he's talking
about so intentional he's saying he's
saying's talking about here's talking
about V this is the takeaway ridiculous
here's a guy that works for a network
that constantly spews poison with lies
that's all they do he's that you want
talk about bought and paid for as a
grown man were you shaking from what w
was saying because it's the truth it's
the truth when he said January 6 Inside
Job 100% 100% what what's making you
shake and by the way he has to be that
guy because Trump didn't talk so they
have to have him what what was he
supposed to say right there yeah I mean
dude everybody ass CNN production
meeting van Jones y'all you better take
this guy seriously I got a plan I got
this give me the point point at the 8
Minute Mark I'm going after him I was
shaking that's the CNN pre-production
let me just tell you what this guy's got
here's here's what you got to give an
Jones credit he's right vivec's going to
be around for 40 50 years yeah that and
you're going to have to put up with him
and the guy is probably the most
annoying guy to people like van Jones He
is fearless he is he has his own money
smart he is educated he is has made his
own money he's doing his thing he is
well read he has outworked everybody
he's on every single Show podcast he's
not said no to anybody we offered Nikki
Haley she was supposed to come here
today the debate was in Miami last
minute oh we just can't because of all
this other C Chris Christie oh last
minute credit to RFK just did a town
hall credit to deanes he came over here
credit to Vic he's come here a couple
times Niki haly establishment doesn't
want to come why don't you want to come
and sit down why don't you want to do
this they understand a guy like vivec is
going to be annoying talking [__] about
these guys for a very very long time to
come and they're going to hate her by
the way it's so bad that even Larry
thinkink had to respond to Vic here's a
story with Larry thinkink talking about
Larry fin dismisses sad criticism of
Black Rock and Republican deay this is a
financial time story Larry fin has
criticized Republican presidential
candidates for repeatedly mentioning the
asset manager during a recent debate
calling it a sad commentary on the state
of American politics he expresses dismay
stating Black Rock was mentioned by some
candidates in last last night's debate
more than inflation or national debt
that's a sad commentary on the state of
American
politics during the debate vivec
ramaswami accused think of being the
king of woke industrial complex which he
is and claimed that his support for
Nikki Haley could influence her
ramaswami an anti-g advocate do you have
that clip where he talks about uh uh uh
uh
Reed Hastings and what Reed Hastings
he's calling him the second George Soros
if you can pull that one up and claim
that his support for Nikki Haley would
influencer ramaswami on an anti-g
advocate also accused thinkink of
telling energy companies like Exon and
Chevron where they can drill Ronda
santis Florida's governor boasted about
moving $2 billion in investments from
away from Black Rock stating his actions
as a testament of his stance so watch
watch him right here what he says to
uh uh Nikki Haley he flat out doesn't
think Nikki Haley and Chris Christie are
good people can you imagine having the
audacity to say go and play this by the
way you cannot find this clip for
whatever reason this part of the debate
is tough to find go ahead somebody in
the White House who absolutely is going
to be a fighter when it counts and I did
say that there were some good people on
that stage in that third debate Doug
Bergen was on that stage at that time
and I I'll say that jokingly Ronda is a
good person too I want to go back though
to Nikki Haley's comment from earlier
that she is somehow not responding to
the will of these donors Nikki you were
bankrupt when you left the UN after you
left the UN you became a military
contractor you actually started joining
service on the board of Boeing whose
back you scratched for a very long time
and then gave foreign multinational
speeches like Hillary Clinton is and now
you're a multi-millionaire that math
does not add up it adds up to the fact
that you are corrupt and when I said
they were bought and paid for I meant
the Republican establishment not the
Democratic establishment
now you have Reed Hoffman the person
who's effectively George Soros Jr
funding lawsuits across this country
against Donald Trump to keep him off the
ballot funding leftwing causes we
discover this week that he is one of
Nikki Haley's largest supporters Larry
thinkink the king of the woke industrial
complex the ESG movement the CEO of
Black Rock the most powerful company in
the world now supporting Nikki Haley and
to say that doesn't affect her is false
because it's after that meeting later
that day that she says that every
American needs to be doxed by having
their ID their government issued ID tied
to what they say on the internet so I
think that this is far more corrupt than
I even imagined when I entered politics
but I will say this it is going to take
a leader from the outside with fresh
legs from the Next Generation to unite
this country not the broken politicians
who were puppets of the Puppet Masters
dude let me explain something to you
that
guy wrapped with a punch Trump doesn't
go Pat that guy that guy has my vote
that he is so freaking like you know
dude everybody's quiet nobody was
budding in even the other side was just
like holy [__] captivated by what he's
saying yeah he's a he's a g bro I like
that guy a lot did you say that Larry
fin responded to this that's Larry spin
And the fact I just read the article
Larry finin responded to it yes Tom go
ahead yeah he said that um you know some
candidates are mentioning Black Rock
more than inflation or the national debt
that's a sad Comon on the state of
American politics the reason he said
it's a sad commentary is because he
doesn't have a rebuttal Point uh a
fact-based rebuttal Point what he's
really saying is damn it how did Black
Rock become the flag carrying noun for
the problem of the financial services
industry it's black it's all of us why
don't you bring up Citadel and Ken
Griffin hang on I got to make a text Ken
I'm really sorry says why don't you
bring everybody else up that's what
Larry thinkink is saying is how did
Black Rock become the noun for the be
the flag carrier from F you know the um
you know the private Equity groups uh
like Black Rock are buying up American
single family homes uh like Black Rock
are you know pushing ESG agendas he
doesn't want to be that flag carrier but
guess what you're the biggest you're the
largest you're the most visible you've
said it and congratulations you're the
flag carrier yeah he's going like I mean
if from how you're listening to him the
swamp the left you know you know the
establishment all this he has he's not
going away for 50 years but he has to he
has to watch himself in the fact that
look what they're doing to Trump what
they did to Trump right now he has to be
kind of on on high alert you know what I
mean because he's about to take that
mantle of trump cu no matter what like
you said he's not going if that voice
that that following he's not going
anywhere he be worried did you guys see
should he be worried for his life not
life and all in general because they're
going to they're going to be watching
him listen anytime you're you just have
to realize the one thing about think
about the profile of anti-establishment
and think about the profile of a human
being of establishment what is the
profile of those two types of people
okay the anti-establishment
uh profile is somebody that is pro
Freedom that's somebody that doesn't
like to be controlled somebody that has
a mind of their own somebody that has
their own opinions somebody that uh is
not afraid to talk to anybody I'll sit
down and have a conversation with you
because they're willing to debate the
anti-establishment ideals are that they
are against people controlling you and I
and calling those people out now go to
the establishment the anti-establishment
community is the minority the
anti-establishment community is like
imagine you're
a minority you know going to a school
you're the only Mexican in that school
you're the only Middle Eastern in that
school you're the only black kid in that
school okay you're the only Jew in that
school you're the only Christian in that
you're the only Muslim in that school
you're a minority right
anti-establishment Community is all
minority why because the establishment
owns what the establishment
are the people that went to Harvard are
the people that went to the schools by
the way Vive is a school guy as well but
these guys that go to the schools
they're all of a sudden hooked up
together so meaning hey I'm going to do
favors for you you're going to do this
for me you're going to come and work for
the mainstream media establishment
you're going to come and work for this
paper establishment New York Times
establishment wo establishment you know
you got CNN establishment even Fox MBC
CBS establishment these are all
establishment people who protect each
other because they have the card to get
into the club and these guys are willing
to give up the card these guys don't
care about being the cool guys entering
the club these guys simply want to be
the guys that this is what I stand for
so the group here is massive they have a
lot of power this guy Reed Hoffman he's
talking about he's the founder of
LinkedIn yeah he's the guy yeah Reed
Hoffman is a multi- multibillion started
LinkedIn PayPal Mafia he is one of the
OG OG guys and he called him George
sores Jr so however
what the anti-establishment is doing is
going against the grain and the people
who feel they have that profile they're
relating to it and they're sitting
they're saying I'm interested why is
this guy talking like this if we purely
took one data purely took one data who
grew the
most on Twitter the most from the day
they announced they're running till
today oh not even close V do you know
what the numbers are like I remember you
showed you showed Oh but but
astronomical
it's 23x since we talk about that wow
it's 2 3x since we talked about that as
it should no he's given that message and
he's challeng on a lot of people he's
getting people thinking anyways let's go
to the next story next story is what
happened with the College University so
this last week pen folks this is going
to be very disturbing Rob if you can
pull up that one clip so you got the
president of Harvard you got the
president of MIT you got the president
of Penn being grilled here and look at
their answers and their response and
afterwards I'm going to tell you what
happened with Bill Amman some people
pulling $100 million out but first take
a look at this clip go ahead Rob Dr corn
BL yes does m at MIT does calling for
the genocide of Jews violate mit's code
of conduct or rules regarding bullying
and harassment yes or no if targeted at
individuals not making public
statements yes or no calling for the
genocide of Jews does not constitute
bullying and harassment I have not heard
calling for the genocide for Jews on our
campus but you've heard chancef for
into I've heard chance which can be
anti-semitic depending on the context
when calling for the elimination of the
Jewish people so those would not be
according to the mit's code of conduct
or
rules that would be um investigated of a
as harassment if pervasive and severe
Miss Miguel at Penn does calling for the
Gen side of Jews violate pens rules or
code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment watch this I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
Mill so is your testimony that you will
not answer yes if it uh is if the speech
becomes if the speech becomes conduct it
can be harassment yes conduct meaning
committing the act of genocide is the
dumbest thing the speech is not
harassment this is unacceptable miss m
I'm going to give you one more
opportunity for the world to see your
answer does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Penn's code of conduct when
it comes to bullying and harassment yes
or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes and Dr Gay at Harvard does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate
Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the context what's the context
targeted as an individual targeted as at
an individual it's targeted at Jewish
students Jewish individuals can you
believe that do you understand your
testimony is dehumanizing them do you
understand that dehumanization is part
of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time giving her a chance say calling for
the genocide of Jews viola har rules of
bullying and harassment yes or
no anti-semitic rhetoric when is
anti-Semitic rhetoric anti-semitic
rhetoric when it crosses into conduct
that amounts to bullying harassment
intimidation what that is actionable
conduct and we do take action so the
answer is yes that calling for the
genocide of Jews violates Harvard code
of conduct
correct again so hard on the context it
does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the board first of all you see
this this is like the by far the worst
commercial one could play Tom as a
parent you you know a lot of these
schools you know their numbers you know
where they're at you know what they're
doing one what is your reaction when you
see what they're saying is number two
what do you think the consequence are
going to be of this so I'll take it down
three levels level number one um uh Penn
was on the short list uh for my daughter
the very short list uh Penn at Wharton
has a great undergrad program where you
can also be across uh campus with an
American history degree and then Bailey
wants to go get her MBA what better
place than one of the finest Business
Schools uh Wharton in the US and we took
it off the list and when we saw what
happened over the last year and and by
the way for some people that are
watching saying what do you think you're
going to take it off the list who do you
think you are his daughter got 1560 on
her SATs out of 1,600 trust me this is a
very qualified kid girl young lady
that's got a 4.6 GPA incredible citizen
incredible at what she does and she was
somebody that could get into pen go
ahead Tom she was also editor of the
yearbook and dedicated herself to making
sure that the pages of the yearbook
showed everybody and included everybody
not just your own picture as a student
in 11th grade 12th grade or whatever but
that you were represented beyond your
sport beyond your yearbook picture so
Bailey's very committed to the inclusive
nature you know in modern society and
ensuring people are there but but we
said no so the first level is as a
parent I'm now glad that you know she's
not you know on on her way or in
consideration there but the second point
was you have to understand why they I I
I sat back at this last night and I
looked into it and I said why didn't
they say yes because if they said yes
they have to go back to the campus where
they've had Palestinian protests for the
better part of a month and they got to
go back
they were going back and and they are
coach these are lawyers these are
lawyers by trade and they were sitting
there if you're asked about that you if
you say yes we have to come back and
take action against all of a month of
protest maybe we would have to um
suspend a club's ability to gather on
campus maybe we'd have to kick them off
campus saying hey your Club is full of
hate speech you have to kick him off
campus and so they were I think they
were worried about answering it that way
the next thing that happened is they
forgot got where the real power is the
power at pen is not in the
wallets of the art history students the
power of pen is the major donors to the
Wharton business school that rolls up to
pen yeah the power of the pen cutting
the checks you mean thank you exactly
right I'm not laughing at the but you
you make a very ironic and correct Point
Adam you know that's where it is so
that's my response they couldn't answer
the question in a certain way cuz it
would have caus them to have to go home
and take action well now they may have
to go home and take action because there
are Israeli demonstrations planned today
this afternoon on Harvard Yard and if
you don't think that those um
organizations that were Pro Palestinian
are going to be marching on Harvard Yard
you know I'll you know I I think we're
going to see it come to a head but these
these leaders put themselves in horrible
positions they were checkmated because
if they answer it one way Earth
collapses on their head exhibit a if
they answer it the other way they got to
go home and clean up what they've been
allowing in terms of anti-Semitic
rhetoric for the past two months not two
months but for since October 7th well
that's been it's been that's been over
two months and I I know you're about to
say something so basically what they
would they wouldn't answer uh tomble
what they what they were saying is
basically MIT and Harvard and all these
that you can scream out loud you know we
hate Jews Jews die and everything just
as long as it's not pointed at one
person they can't call it speech and
let's not forget Sally cornbluth from
MIT you know what she is right she's
Jewish how is she how is she sitting
there as a Jewish woman and not being
able to answer that being openly
anti-semitic isn't bullying or
harassment or or anti like that's
unbelievable what what do you think
happens if the if what if that
congresswoman was a person of color and
was asking would calling for the
genocide of African-Americans Hispanic
Americans pick your list
constitute yeah bullying racism and be
unacceptable according to your standards
of conduct and call for Action they
would have said absolutely congresswoman
absolutely of course so we had an
insurance meeting this last week and one
of the uh uh very very powerful
executive in the insurance industry he's
a president he does very well he's known
he's and he's gone to
pen and he's a Jew but he's also a
Democrat okay and he comes and starts
talking with me I love this guy and we
started having a conversation with them
when we see each other we say I love you
I love you like it's Brothers okay he's
one of those guys and he says I got to
tell you man one of the things I'm
having a very hard time with right now
as a Democrat he just openly talks it's
just him and I he I'm having a very hard
time with the fact that how are
Democrats not understanding he says as a
guy that went to these schools how are
they understanding you cannot not allow
this anti-Semitism to be taking place on
school campuses how it says that's
causing some of my friends who are
liberals to leave the way they're voting
y we let me let me explain to you how
weird this is
1960 64% of African-Americans vote
Democrat 36% pretty much vote
conservative 60s you said 1960 got you
so what happens in 1960 to 1964 Barry
Goldwater does his deal
Democrats are able to convince
African-Americans that Democrats were
African-Americans not Republicans it
goes from 1960 where only 64% voted
Democrat to
92% from 1964 till today blacks have
voted Democrat 88 to
94% is what they voted so some elections
94% Democrat 88% 92% 90% but that's been
the
number this incident here could cause
some of the most powerful Jews in the
marketplace to say hey man I'm not I'm
not with this thing let me read this to
you Bill Amman okay Bill Amman who went
to Harvard okay billionaire in Harvard
CL Bill Amman suggests Harvard president
was a Dei pick they picked this person
just because of Dei okay so let me okay
Bill Harvard grad Billman criticized the
selection of Harbor's president implying
that the diversity Equity inclusion
policies played a role in said someone
with the firstperson knowledge someone
with first person knowledge indicated
that the committee would not consider
the candidate who did not meet the Dei
office criteria okay he argued against
narrowing candidate pools based on race
gender and sexual orientation criteria
stating shrinking the pool of candidates
based on race gender or sexual
orientation is not the right approach
Amman voiced concerns over Harvard's
handling of anti-Semitism freedom speech
and the impact of office Equity
diversity inclusion and belonging
oedi at University so that's be Amman
now secondly you're story about a
billionaire you upen this is for
upen donor withdraws $100 million of
donation after president's Congressional
testimony on
anti-Semitism $100 million $100 million
upend donor Ross Stevens Ross when you
here Ross Ross Stevens who pledged
approximately $100 million to establish
a financial Innovation Center is
withdrawing his donation due to concerns
about the University's handling of
anti-Semitism and president Liz McGill's
congre Congressional testimony on the
subject stating president Mill's
December 6 2023 post on Twitter admitted
as much when she uh blatantly
acknowledge only after her Congressional
testimony went viral and demands for her
termination Amplified fight that calls
for genocide of the Jews people
constitute harassment and discrimination
that's when she flipped after she almost
lost her job Steven's attorney argued
that upen violated its limited
partnership agreement with Stoneridge
Asset Management by failing to adher to
anti-discrimination and anti-harassment
rules saying that they are appalled by
the university stance on anti-Semitism
on campus the way whose rules were they
they were the ones that Congressman
spanic was asking you know president
if she would she would
follow is this the on that and he's
talking about the rules for Penn and
McGill this is what Congressman sted was
asking do you think according to your
own rules and this this guy's like hey
your own rules are in this thing called
a contract and a contract for a donation
and a contract to create a financial
Innovation Center so he's asking the
same question and he's referencing a
contract Congressman stepanic was asking
the same question and referencing their
own standards well friendly advice to
anybody that's
ever in testimony in front of Congress
in front of a jury in front of anybody
in front
ofas any cameras anytime someone asks
you to make a public statement on
genocide take the other stance against
genocide no one's going to get mad at
you for basically saying I firmly stand
against any calls for Gen of any people
of any minority of any type of
persuasion genocide is wrong it should
never be allowed any calls for it should
be vehemently stand against how hard is
that to freaking say nobody will come
after you and say I am against genocide
how dumb are these [__] leaders of
these major schools yeah let me ask you
a question yeah what is the likelihood
okay over under what is the
likelihood that those three had a
conference call or a meeting and or were
prepared and role played questions that
we going to ask and how to react and how
for all of them be on the same page what
is the likelihood that that took place I
did some calculations over the weekend I
think it was
10.62% 105.6 2% I'm going with that how
about this if there's anything that you
were doing it was tallying up
percentages guarant the likelihood that
three presidents of three of the most
prominent schools two based in Boston by
the way one in Penn about an hour or two
down the road actually even knew each
other before this Congressional hearing
I mean a million percent of yeah they
probably have each other's numbers they
probably been in contact of so the fact
that they're coming into Congress right
now to have this testimony they thought
like they're not on the surface idiots
course of course by the way this was the
most viewed Congressional testimony in
history whoa okay history has spoken oh
w wow so they can go home and tell their
family their here is right here Adam
while you're looking at is it really the
most this is Wall Street Journal the
pathetic Wall Street Journal the
pathetic testimony of the Harvard Penn
and MIT presidents have been viewed more
than a billion times worldwide making it
the most viewed Congressional testimony
in history deservedly so because it
shocked the of the world the only
acceptable consequence is that the
boards immediately replace them with
leaders who will restore
morality by the way if that's the number
this is by far the worst commercial a
university could have had period the
worst commercial you could have had
period there's not a worse advertisement
for universities than what just happened
right now and Adam because P you said
Jewish donors like they're they're
they're jumping ship right what's the
percentage I mean I don't know if
there's a stat for Jewish people that
vote Democrat and how much you think
that that's going to change that 65%
Jews are
65 it's been 2/3 1/3 great question do
you think that's going to change votes 1
million per there should be good uh a
lot of Jewish people and a lot of people
for that matter just with yeah a brain
that's looking at whatever is going on
this Progressive left woke Hamas caucus
okay yeah that should be saying hey I
voted this way for a while and and by
the way guilty is charged because I was
a JFK Democrat a Bill Clinton Democrat
yeah if you were a JFK Democrat or Bill
Clinton Democrat you would probably be a
Joe Mansion Democrat which is pretty
much a moderate Republican at this point
but if you look at the infected of
what's going on the Progressive
Progressive left it's disgusting to
watch and at the end of the day you
could look at the people on the far left
and look at the people on the far right
and anybody that's far left or far right
I you know extremism I do not Advocate
that but at the very least the very
least you could say that the people on
the far right love America the problem
with the people on the far left they
actually hate America and what America
stands for and they're trying to rewrite
history in this Progressive woke way and
to me as someone that's basically been
sort of politically homeless for the
last handful of years I don't know I'm
not really trying to uh you know storm
the capital at the same time I'm not
trying to fight for Hamas where do I
land here but moral Clarity is
completely seen in
these institutions of Higher Learning
presidents and if they can't even take a
stand against genocide we've lost our
way and great him and you and you
mentioned this a bunch of times and this
was I want to say a month maybe two
months ago when I was like Patrick these
everything how do people not see it and
you sat right here and you know you said
give it time you go bad policies bad
ideas bad things they come to light and
this was one of those moments Adam where
I went oh [__] I can't believe that
they're saying you can't say out loud
that screaming for a whole race of
people to be exterminated you can't say
that out of your mouth holy [__] the lay
you know you know three out of the top
six universities in the world with the
biggest endowment are those three 100%
three out of six Harvard's number one
and I think pen and MIT are 56 Harvard's
got around 50 to 60 billion the other
two have 20 to $30 billion of endowment
they're sitting on do you know what's
happened to them last three years these
are frauds they told the American people
they're about higher education during
covid kids are not going to school
they're not staying on campus they're
not going out there needing the food
they didn't lower the money the tuition
for parents to pay by a penny they still
expected you to pay as if your kids are
on campus going to school from home on a
zoom they said you still have to pay the
full price think about what a dirt bag
mentality and they're sitting on $ 51
billion you're sitting on one you did
that two your woke [__] you're doing
your LGBT stuff that you're feeding down
kids throat your hate of America and
then now you're showing us with this
your
imagine as somebody that's raising kids
sitting I want my kids to go to this
school are you out of your flipping mind
have you lost your mind and we're
supposed to send our kids to you to lose
them I was at Harvard in 2016 when
Hillary and Trump are debating the
debate where they said because you'd be
in jail that debate I watched it in
Harvard in their chow hall with 300
other people Harvard's chow hall is an
Asian man that paid for the uh the
restaurant where where you eat the food
it's called cho
cho I'm sitting there Vinnie there was
not one person of the 300 people that
supported Trump wow
100% of everybody who was there watching
this were 100% for Hillary Clinton not
one person not one person I go back the
next day and I bring it up to the
professors I said why is it all of you
hate Trump no we don't there's not one
of Are You Gonna vote for oh no I would
never vote for him I said all I'm
supposed to come to your school and
every single one of you hates Trump is
that is that really debate is that
really how school's supposed to be I
said I'm not coming back the next two
cuz the way their OPM program works is
you go one and then you go another one
and you go I said I'm not say no you
should come back I said I'm not coming
back to be in a what to be in a sounding
board where all you guys are sitting
here and agreeing on the fact that
Hillary Clinton's because what so you
know right for me you know what's right
for me your establishment now I think I
think the last few years revealed what
these people stand for and I'm telling
you right now this whole thing about uh
uh we're having this conversation last
night I I spoke to four different places
last night I finished up last I don't
what time I don't even know what time we
got home last night 1:00 a.m. 2 a.m. no
literally I saw videos of you of like 10
different locations I'm here here first
of all the last few weeks have been
insane but so I'm going to all these
different places and I'm sitting there
talking about what decision Tom and I
made parents listen parents academics is
important
studying and learning to do homework and
all that stuff is important yes I'm not
going to sit you and say I'm okay with
my kids not doing it it's important high
standards is important is academics more
important than values and principles I
don't know about that because to me if
somebody is a winner and they want to
compete they're going to compete do they
need to be around other people to
compete yes at the cost of manipulation
and brainwashing no I'm not good with
that can you still create a CL inment
for your kids to be able to debate and
be around other guys where they can kind
of stand up for themselves yes is there
a benefit of going to a school where the
school is 70% Democrats and maybe you're
conservative but they're actually
reasonable human beings yes I think
there's a benefit to that because your
kids going to learn how to debate but
today that's not the case out of 13
professors Rob pull up pull this up
right now what percentage of professors
are Democrats to Republicans for every
one conservative Professor is 13
Democrats what for every one
conservative Professor I'll find this
article for you it's either 13 to1 or 12
something like that it's it's no no it's
I'll show you it's 13 to1 like 5%
professors yes that is bananas 13 to1 is
not in a monopoly rule you call that
there's a 16 to1 that one right there go
to that one right
there 16 to1 how recent is that article
how long ago is that by the way and I
said 13 to1 I was being friendly that's
a year ago I remember in 2020 when we
were talking about the election it
actually was 13 to to1 so it's only gone
up since then here we
go Business Insider why are so many
Democrat professors Democrats this is
2016 a college professor wrote a biting
explanation why so many professors are
Democrats out of 13 professors 12 were
Democrats okay and this is 2016 when it
was a 12:1 ratio now it's a 16 to1 ratio
y in the same University you're sending
your kids to be baptized by these guys
it ain't even fair it's like bullying
imagine you're fighting with 16 other
people 13 other people nobody else can
be in there to do that debate with you
that's that's the climate we have right
now with this is the problem with the
woke Dei agenda because they're focused
on Race on sex on gender on sexual
orientation but Dei what I would want on
campus on institutions of Higher
Learning are diversity of thought yeah
of different ideas how what exactly what
we do on this show the beauty of what
pbd said let's get a bunch of guys with
different opinions let's work this [__]
out but what happens on these college
campuses is they basically exclude
anyone with a different thought of them
let a Ben Shapiro or Charlie Kirk try to
show up on campus forget good luck guys
they don't let a let a Hamas terrorist
show up on campus thank you for coming
Muhammed akar yeah let's show you let's
show you the basement come on in here
but ex exactly what pbd talks about
policies have consequences so here's
what's going on here so Lewis brandise
the Chief Justice there's a school after
named after him uh called brandise said
what sunlight or transparency is the
best disinfectant we are
disinfecting what is happening on these
woke college campuses and Pat talks
about institutions of higher education
these are institutions of higher
indoctrination and it's becoming
completely obvious so if you look at
what's going on in Harvard you've
mentioned this earlier uh Dr Tom bisoc
Harvard just this year placed dead last
among 248 universities on the foundation
for individual rights and expressions
college free speech rankings receiving
only a score of zero out of a 100 I
don't even know what the hell that is
and you're saying that in second place
AKA second to last is pen at 247 how do
you get a score of zero out of 100 on
Harvard's foundation for individual
rights and expression but here's
something for you I don't know if you
can Decades of trump I don't know if you
can look at this this is on the Wall
Street Journal this is the leader the
president so here's the article Harvard
bans sis hetero ISM okay het
heterosexism but shrugs and
anti-Semitism so what constitutes
bullying and harassment at Harvard these
days mandatory Title 9 you've talked
about this yeah warned that all
undergraduate students are banned from
CIS headism okay fat phobia using the
wrong pronouns any of that would be
called abuse and violence on campus
violent calling someone fat calling
someone fat even worse is violent what
do but it's
violent genocide of Jews context look
yeah what do you mean by genoci what
kind of genci worst thing for these
School presidents is for the average
American to know their names did any of
you know any of these Le every
time I was like what and by the way now
now for somebody a would by the way I
don't even know what I scored on my SS
that's how bad it probably was now I'm
just like to help Harvard schmarvard but
shout out to Elise stefanic Republican
representative from New York I think she
was the first Republican to win in her
District since 90s she just Italian
she's no I don't even know what she is
doesn't matter she's just a person with
she stepping up moral Clarity okay
where's she from early life she's from
New York she's a representative of New
York Che she held all three of these to
the fire leaders of the to the fire of
the highest institutions of learning in
this country she made them look like
absolute [__] can I ask you a question
did did the Republican side uh question
these people as well with that much
Vigor she's she's the Republican no I'm
saying who's the Democrat were there any
Democrats yelling at these idiots there
actually was um that's what I'm saying
we just the Tom you know what I'm saying
she's the only clip that basically I've
seen did anybody else dig into them on
the left like was there any Jewish
people that are in Congress that were
like yo what are you talking about or
did they stay quiet that's you know what
I mean p that's the only viral clip that
I saw well when where the people when
that ridiculous clip makes it to the
news it just takes all the oxygen out of
the room nobody spoke EX on anything
it's the most viewed Cong ever in a
billion in a week in a Day Vinnie oh my
it was a day it was yesterday
unbelievable that's good for her by the
way watch what this leads to so now
handing the voting block this morning
this morning I'm at uh Dylan's got a
game so I run up to it he's playing and
um at the same time I Mee him with a guy
we're having a conversation he's a big
producer in Hollywood and done work
everybody knows uh some of the work this
guys down we're having this conversation
together and then the conversation leads
to what's going on with uh Hollywood
movies being made who's winning who's
not winning and some are going far left
that didn't work some are going far
right that didn't work and Hollywood's
about coming down more about just purely
entertainment and if you want to give
your message maybe subtle but not crazy
entertainment so then Elon Musk we
haven't reacted to this yes La last week
with Bob ier he's got a feud so he's
being interviewed New York Times we've
not reacted to this right but before you
give that did you see what he said about
this exact situation we
justed so samman who Jewish that he was
you know we just we covered what's going
on with him so this goes to your point
Sam ultman he's the chat gbt uh yeah the
nice man who three weeks ago had a very
busy weekend exactly he made a post uh
basically saying oh wow anti-Semitism on
the left is way worse than I thought and
Elon Moss tweeted yep agreed so like I
get we're I know we're moving on to Elon
mus and what he did with with Bob Iger
and everything like that but just to
kind of wrap that up with a ribbon on it
basically here it is I don't know for
long like that anti-em in particular was
on the American left was not as bad as
people claimed I'd like to I'd like to
just state that I was totally wrong I
still don't understand it really or know
what what to do about it but it's so
effed and then El says yes yes so then
so then Elon so then all these people
just to be clear all these people
whether it's Elon whether it's Sam Alman
whether it's Bill Amman these guys were
all voting on the left that's right just
a few years ago just a couple years ago
now they're running to the here what so
Elon is being asked this question about
the positions he's making and the
comments he's making and whatever he's
by the way some of this stuff he got
comment for being considered an
anti-semite some people said to him
about the comments he was making but
watch this interview here with New York
Times and Elon and look how Elon reacts
to specifically calling out Bobby grin
go
ahead if you will that this had been
said online there was all of the
criticism there was advertisers leaving
we talked to Bob Iger I hope they stop
you hope uh don't advertise you don't
want them to advertise no what do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go [__]
yourself he doesn't know what to say
look at the guy he knows this video is
about to go viral go [__]
yourself is that
clear I hope it is hey hey Bob in the
audience he Bob
ask you that's Andrew Ross sorin one of
the biggest names on CNBC I mean
credible journalist de book this is his
this is his mini conference I believe he
was the found oh he's the one that put
this on gotcha so this leads to people
talking asking well what are you going
to do you know you need the money you
know this company dropped that company
dropped this company dropped they're not
going to be doing advertisement for you
what's your reaction when you see what
Elon says here with this finny I I I
first of all you know the necklace that
he's wearing Elon you know what is he
went to Israel and he got that I guess
somebody he's wearing that until every
single hostage is released from what you
didn't know that that that that
Medallion that he has on his neck but
this clip right here uh no he he has a
medallion but anyway Pat when I when I
see something like that I think it's
somebody that's obviously doesn't hate
any race a guy that's you know trying to
save the human race with all the all the
Innovation that he's doing to try to get
him and try to go against money I love
the attitude of that's go Fu money when
you have that attitude you have that
much money all the stuff that they
always tripad it's nobody with that much
like they don't really go after
billionaires like this for that attitude
that's basically saying for the threat
Fu I respect the [__] out of him for
that Tom I I think there's a difference
between Fu money and the attitude people
say man look at that athlete man he's
not cow anymore because he's got Fu
money they say the same thing about
celebrities there's two sides to it one
side of Fu money is now you get to be
arrogant do whatever the hell you want
in life and okay but I I don't I'm not a
big fan of that the other side of it is
you have enough resources and I'm not
going to call it Fu money you have
enough resources that you can stick to
your principles and live through what
they want to throw at you in terms of
cancelling and that is where Elon Musk
is he has enough resources that he can
take the stance people say he's got Fu
money no it's not Fu money he is saying
go f yourself you have listen to what he
said right up in front of it wait a
minute blackmail me blackmail me with
money yep he's like he's saying I can
surf pass that wave if you want to throw
it at me now watch this here's what's
crazy El publicly called for the removal
removal of Bob Iger Co Disney CEO
criticizing Disney's decision not to
remove ads from meta platforms emit uh
amid allegations of child exploitation
stating he should be fired immediately
musk accused Iger of endorsing
advertising alongside child exploitation
material asking why no advertisers
boycott Bob Iger you are endorsing this
material he also questioned the CMO of
companies advertising on these platforms
saying why do their Chief marketing
officers endorse child trafficking let's
ask them musk accused these advertisers
of effectively blackmailing him saying
if someone is going going to try and
blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go f yourself so the whole
premise about this conversation was why
are you get so advertising on uh
Facebook if this is so important why are
you doing it yeah or is it just about
politics or is it just about what I
stand or just about the fact that I'm
challenging the status quo so this guy's
not slowing down I love it no he's a
he's a very necessary voice with what
he's doing right now and Pat I I said
Rob I sent you the the slack P about the
necklace just so people understand the M
this this is the guy that we're supposed
to think hates Jewish people goad uh Rob
Rob if you could play there you
go why don't you tell
everybody this is this
says says bring them
home the
hostages it was given to me by the
parents of of one of the
hostages and I said I would wear it as
as long as there was a hostage store
remaining and I have the Jewish people
have been been persecuted for thousands
of years everyone here has seen the the
massive demonstrations for Hamas in
every major city in the west including
schools that should be jarring yeah you
know what I mean that's that's dude that
I'm supposed to believe that this guy
hates Jewish people give me a [__]
break sorry for language well
you it you tell me did he seem a little
emotional as he was saying that he was
about to cry okay I've never seen Elon
Musk ever show any real type with 60
minutes where he was being judged you
you're Jewish you don't feel dude oh
well look I he's come out and said that
he's sort of on the Spectrum right he's
he said
that that that is known for not having
emotion so the fact that something like
this moves him to emotion just shows
that you know he feels very deeply about
this look as far as the Elon Musk
companies we've seen this happen before
shortterm
um they could take a hit right they're
going to lose some advertising I'm sure
their CEO Linda Yaro of Twitter on X is
not happening there's Vinnie did an
amazing video about that what's going on
over there but we've seen this happen
when he went and smoked weed with Rogan
Tesla stock took a hit a little bit but
they they reach all times after that I
think that you know as Pat always says
that X or Twitter is going to be a
trillion dollar company one day this is
just sort of a blip on the radar right
now
and he's going to fight through this
just like he fought through everything
but he's it's good to know that he's
making a moral distinction between a
democratic Ally of the United States or
a stepchild of the Iranian terrorist
organization Hamas good to know that we
have that moral Clarity on what's going
on here in America today by the way let
me read this to you so this next Story
by California California's budget
deficit swells to record $68 billion as
tax revenue
Falls uh California's budget deficit has
sort to 68 billion surpassing earlier
estimates of $4.3 billion okay which
represent which presents a significant
fiscal challenge the deficit stems from
unexpectedly ready low tax revenue I
wonder why I wonder why you have a low
tax revenue huh while acknowledging the
severity of the deficit state budget
analysts have emphasized the
availability of options to address it
includes these include you utilizing
cash reserves implementing one-time
spending cuts and revising education
funding the budget shortfall resulted
from various factors including delayed
tax filing deadlines analysts projected
a staggering $ 58 billion Revenue
shortfall highlighting concerns about
the state's Financial stability future
deficits are anticipated with
recommendations to preserve a portion to
of reserves for future challenges Tom
can you tell us why this has happening
to this great incredible State of
California
it's very very simple there's not enough
people making enough and paying taxes
people talk about property taxes let me
draw a line
there excuse me sorry about that it's
okay Tom property taxes go to get
emotional when he has to pay taxes
property C property taxes go sort of the
County City whereas this the the um uh
state income tax which in California is
up to 13.3 and Rising going to set new
records they going to lead the nation in
that good luck they're record you want
to be leading in they yep that's not
what you want to be leading but damn it
they're trying and they're going to win
so number one it's um uh state income
tax and then number two it's you know
the cor corporate income tax in the
state and then number three is like gas
tax and stuff there's not enough people
in California with jobs paying taxes and
now there's a shortfall a b there hasn't
been the artificial windfall of some of
the when you see a Silicon Valley
company has that has an IPO and it goes
out and it's really big venture
capitalist people in there as a matter
of fact I know for a fact that the
Facebook IPO
alone gave California a get out of jail
free card for one and a half years on
their state budget that's how much tax
revenue they got from the Facebook IPO
and so there's not enough people there
they're leaving they can say everything
they want oh no no more people are
coming to California from Texas and
going to Texas baloney the people are
leaving there's not enough taxpayers and
as they raise the taxes and raise the
rhetoric more people are leaving that's
the problem they have and for
Educational Funding if one of the things
they want to cut is Educational Funding
cut the entire UC system please cut the
fire breathing liberal sus poool that is
the UC system just cut it and save the
the state money but that's what's going
people are leaving what is this
California us to bank millions in taxes
Facebook IPO yeah this goes way back
right 189 million in taxes for the State
of California that's a number and so
people are leaving and there's not
enough people left to pay the taxes and
and more Governor handout keeps handing
things out only one problem you can't
run a deficit as a state in the United
States of America you know what they
would be called you can't California
would be considered a zombie State yeah
like a zombie California is a zombie
State the only thing they can live off
of is is its people's money and
constantly going into debt California is
the Ultimate Zombie State Bingo even
though they're a top five GDP in the
world bro let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question you ready let me
ask you a question um think about how
much money you make per year okay you
ever met anybody that makes a $100,000
can a person making $100,000 a year be
richer than a person making a million
dollars a year yeah of course if if they
if they don't B have a budget and they
spend all their money like most
Americans you mean to tell me somebody
making a million dollars a year could be
richer than somebody making 10 million a
year yes absolutely you mean to tell me
somebody making 10 million a year could
be richer than somebody making a 100
million a year see what you're doing
here my friend what am I doing here
brother how you don't make more money
it's not about how much you make it's
how much you keep youing with a p some
of your friends make way more money than
you but I'm willing to bet you're richer
than them yeah cuz I I save that money
that's the point so so so guess what
Bingo these guys California is the
Ultimate Zombie State mhm okay and I
don't mean zombie like zombies are
coming out chasing you down although
that's very possible in California no
this is a state that lives off of its
debt and its taxpayers so to my friends
whom I love dearly from California who
love that beach tax who love that
weather tax who love the mountain tax
who love the hill tax who love the Earth
Cafe tax who love the Hollywood
Boulevard tax who love the Chinese
Theater tax who love the Bboy Club
Newport Beach tax who loved the
Manhattan Beach tax I don't know what
you're doing right now what about the
no I don't know what this impersonation
is but I like
it it's very like 999 of and you suckers
never got your highspeed train from LA
to San Francisco psych well the guy that
was going to do it left to Texas weird
he was a guy that was going to do it for
them but Nome pissed them off and it
says screw you I'm out of here that's
weird and I go to Texas yeah he he was
supposed to do the project he was
working with I want to say he was
working with uh uh Emmanuel Rah Emanuel
I think that was matter of fact that was
talked about in musk's book when you get
to the last 25% he talks about that part
now we we had this event this last week
at so
house which was a fantastic by the way
did you hang out did you spend some time
or no did you guys go out last night or
no no but maybe tonight he's okay got it
perfect so but sick event by the way
phen
great Adam the crew invites we had a lot
of good friends there you know Usman was
there Ryan Garcia was there a bunch of
boxers Rashad you know who was partying
the hardest that night who was Usman was
he all over I I'd run into him at a
different place he had a
sung he's he's be here it was great it
was great there was a lot of people
there was a great party but couple of
friends from California were there that
night yeah and I was having a
conversation with them saying when are
you leaving your great state of
California their loyalty to Nome is
unbelievable the level of loyalty they
have for this wonderful sweetheart of a
guy which by the way I would love to sit
down and talk to that guy one of these
days and I'd love to have his I feel
like Nome would come I think he would I
think he would by the way just we I
don't know if we actually fully covered
the debate between Nome and Des santis
it just shows you personality
can and typically will win over
policy every piece of data point was in
desantis's favor in that debate it was
ridiculous okay with the exception of
the six-week abortion ban that obviously
didn't really favor that's I mean
Newsome got him on that every piece of
tax data every piece of crime of
homelessness any type of metric was in
desantis's favor people moving out of
California it was just so it was a
master class on how you can't even win a
debate if you don't have personality
Gavin won this debate with no data on
his side it was it was actually let's
talk about somebody else with a
different kind of personality who spends
a lot of money on prostitutes and
hookers uh Hunter Biden let's talk about
Hunter Biden okay one of one of Vinnie's
favorite guys in politic are these new
stories Hunter Biden not just the John
he's their King Hunter Biden spends
spent uh
$872,000 on hookers porn and sex club
membership this is according to Newsweek
can you pull up the Newsweek uh uh uh
item please okay here we go some of you
guys that claim you party hard you ain't
got nothing on Hunter B Hunter Biden has
been indicted on nine tax charges
including three felony charges and six
misdemeanor charges the indictment
alleges that Biden spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars on lavish lifestyle
including drugs escorts and girlfriends
luxury hotels and rental properties
exotic cars clothing and other items of
personal nature the charges relate to a
period between 2016 and 2019 prosecutors
claim that Biden used various deductions
to avoid paying taxes including
categorizing expenses such as his
daughters Law School tuition house
rentals for his girlfriend and payments
to escorts and dancers as business
deductions the indictment also states
that Biden spent $10,000 on a sex club
membership during this time oh so here
it is these are these are actual numbers
by the way let's go through them listed
in the indictment are the following
alleged payments number one various
women $683,000 hly clothing and
accessories $ 397 educational purposes
who the hell knows what that means
$39,000 Health Beauty and Pharmacy
$237,000 by the way Pharmacy could mean
a lot of different things what do you
think miscellaneous retail purchases
$236,000 Grocery and restaurants
Insurance 203 adult Entertain You got
the more adult entertainment 189 okay
that's a pretty big what's the
difference between D entertainment in
various women who knows man rehab by the
way look at rehab
$72,000 credit card payments 58 advisers
from Wells Fargo 53 entertainment 24
sports and recreation $23,000 total
payments listed in the indictment amount
to $4.9 million wow $4.9 million
so Vinnie your thoughts on this story
well well first of I mean every what is
it every month or every every two month
something is coming out about him I
think the timing of this what people
need to realize is I think this is for
this to come out cuz his father I think
Rob is somewhat going to be connected to
some of this some of this money because
last week we heard something about him
getting payments of
$680 I think the timing of it is good
because they're going to uh tie in Joe
Biden and say oh listen we're not just
going after Joe Biden we're going after
Trump as well and this is I think one of
their plots uh Pat to get to the point
where they're going to say he's not
going to be able to run and this is
going to link into his father but uh
going back to um Hunter bro is it just
is it just like me or they should be
telling him to shut the hell up cuz he
did a Mobi you know Mobi the the singer
he went on his podcast I think yesterday
Mobi has a podcast M has a
podcast is that the one yeah and he was
so he was was saying uh he was saying
stuff there's not much difference uh
from that when fox went on a tear that I
was in some way connected to funding
he's by the way he's on drugs when he's
on this thing uh for sure that I was
funding the Wuhan lab to create covid
but also then it went into the entire
Russian defense Ministry held a two-hour
press conference to explain how George
Soros and I were funding bioweapons labs
in Ukraine and he goes I'm not this is
what he's talking about about the
Republicans he goes I'm not going to let
these mother effers use me just another
example of why people in recovery are
never going to be okay never to be
trusted they are all degenerates and he
goes on to say that uh representative
Marjorie Taylor green uh or Paul goer uh
and some of these guys are bullies
they're just absolutely suffering
suffering people and that's why they're
going after me it's just it's it's again
Mr Untouchable he can literally do you
guys any of you guys think he's going to
get in trouble or go to jail for this be
honest go to jail no will he pay fines
and have some sort of legal restitution
he should fines and but I mean but
literally sons of presidents don't go to
jail D mean no Untouchable crackhead on
the planet is this guy right here and
for him to go on a podcast and say that
he's the victim we're the we're the
problem the the the Republicans
everybody's the problem because we're
suffering because he's an adct and they
should know that this is this is the
life that he chose well I think I found
the problem and it's in the numbers the
problem is in the numbers can you bring
the numbers back Rob and let's go down I
love when Tom talks like a game show
host exactly here it is we're about to
find out let's go how much you spend on
hookers no let's go let's go to I found
the problem in 2016 go down to like line
10 rehab dring alcohol Vinnie how much
did he spend in 16
$7,600 how much in 2017 28,600 Tom how
much in 2018 35,6 669 how much in 2019
not a red scent Thomas I found the
problem he cut the wrong thing out of
the budet yeah that's hilarious there we
go by the way by the way by the way we
also got you we got email we got an
email from the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame there are 12 living members of the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame that are
pissed that Hunter Biden has beaten most
of their records in many of these
categories and it's funny Tom the wells
far advisors and his Roth IRA Adam you'd
be mad about this in 2017 to 2019
nothing and then his home help cleaning
and child care dropped off in 2018 and
2019 that means his house is shitty we
saw the videos this place is a wreck and
you can see he hasn't paid for cleaning
since 2018 yeah it's it's it's it's
pretty bad bro now now he's out there at
Art Basel down the street in Miami
selling his art at one of the nft fair
that's going on you know what drives me
crazy Pat cuz I have these liberal by
the way I have family members that are
still antitrump Trump's the devil th if
this was any Trump Jr can you hold on
can you imagine CNN right now would be
on fire they'd be apoplectic oh Tom I
have no idea what that word means but I
agree because I feel like you know what
it means but but do you understand what
I'm saying can you imagine if it was the
other side but I'm not going to front I
do want just one day cuz mind you I'm
sober over 6 months I would if there's
anybody I would want to party with is
Hunter Bing because could you imagine
pretty sure we've all had a good time in
our lifetime you especially can you
imagine having like security meaning
Secret Service watching every like he's
doing it with Secret Service protection
you can do whatever and the mess is
going to get cleaned by the government
that's amazing that's the guy you want
to party with well I'm I'm going to look
into solutions for a second here like
the fact that he's on Moby's podcast and
I haven't heard M's name in since Eminem
song when he said uh M yeah exactly old
baldheaded go got Academy Award for the
Jason how is the Biden Administration
not checking this guy into rehab whether
it's needed or not and saying vanish bro
oh my God don't be seen don't be talked
about don't be in the news you like this
is absurdity at the highest level here
yeah I I partied some people South Peach
this is next Lev ridiculous it's nonstop
it's nonstop I would put this guy under
a basement somewhere in a rehabs
somewhere and says please do not
resurface until 2025 here's my question
why why hasn't they why of Fame Tom this
is honest question why aren't they
stopping like this guy is a ticking Time
Bomb that's already gone off a couple
times it's like what what are you doing
if this was any other president cocaine
in the white house and we have what did
you see what did you see yesterday we
were talking about they're talking uh
privately on in any moment Joe Biden
could be asked to step down or uh not
running for reelection what what were
you talking about yesterday on the drive
to the one of the meetings yeah I I I
feel as many people do I'm not alone on
this
that the ability of the democratic party
to suppress certain storylines and to
get a harmonization of a mainstream
media narrative is welln it's absolutely
wellknown if they don't want to talk
about something they're not going to
talk about something if they want to
talk about Lauren bobbert behaving
really badly in a movie theater they're
going to talk about that for two weeks
right yeah if they don't want to talk
about something they don't want to talk
about I think this is like we're going
to stay with our theme Here nail in the
coffin this is one of many nails in the
coffin that I think is already being
orchestrated because Joe Biden is not
going to be the the candidate when
November rolls around and I agree with
what I'm hearing from many people that
it will happen with the superdelegate
shift at the convention so what we were
talking about in the car I think the fix
is in and they are allowing a lot of the
stuff to come out and they're allowing
the mainstream media they're even
pushing it so that it's out there in
front of the voters so that when Biden
steps aside at the convention nothing to
see here he's old and he's got to go
take care of his attic son we're moving
on I think that's the play and we're
seeing
it I think I I I think it's going to be
deeper than the going help in the adct
sun I think using the
and his name on some of these payments
and all the you know corruption that I
mean this is just adding to the pie look
you will know that there is only 24
hours left in the political life of Joe
Biden yeah when he pardons Hunter for
all this and that's what's going to Happ
that's what that's what's going to
happen he's going to Pardon his son end
to end for everything and you will know
there's 24 hours left and that will be a
quiet pardon that happens either
immediately after the convention or
going into the convention and I know we
talked about how Trump has approval
ratings versus VI uh Biden's approval
ratings they've sort of been within that
margin of error they both are pretty low
this is the number one story on Wall
Street Journal right now if you look at
the app officially Trump takes 2024 lead
as Biden approval hits new low this is a
new Wall Street Journal poll number one
story on their
thing but that this is a this is a
general electorate type poll but if you
look at the Battleground States if you
look at Nevada if you look at Georgia if
you look at PA if you look at Wisconsin
if you look at Michigan Trump's up four
five even 10 points in these states
those are the concerning things for the
Biden Administration right now in the
DNC do you have that poll is that the
poll that you were just talking can you
go to the poll on how it shows the
movement because uh when I looked at his
chart it showed the movement on what it
was before is that in here or no no
that's the actual Wall Street Journal
article got it and by the way have you
seen yeah I saw that that's kind of what
I wanted to see but have you seen take a
screenshot and maybe send him the
article so he has it have you seen what
have you seen what Melania Trump just
said what uh Melania Trump just recently
said she would like uh she thinks Tucker
would be a great vice president
candidate where did that come from like
where did that where does that come out
of the blue like when have you ever
heard an ex president's wife going you
know what I like that guy to be the vice
president that means she probably heard
something what you mean it came out of
that blue right there yeah yeah exactly
you know she heard something come on
come on she heard something and went I
like them you know when's the first time
anybody said anything about Tucker being
a VP it was on this podcast I wait let
me guess it was called the alliance
between Elon Tucker and Trump and by the
way you know what just came up about
Tucker did you hear the story about what
the negotiation was why he went on X
watch this year this is the story Rob do
you have that or
no on on uh Tucker going uh starting his
media company and what he got with
Twitter and exchange is that the one is
that the one that ISS all let me see if
it's in there or not if not can pull it
up I'll show you the article as well and
I talked about this a couple of months
ago so here we go Tucker Carlson New
Media Company moves forward I think they
raised 15 million bucks a couple months
ago um we are opened our site for
membership sales subscribers will gain
access to exclusive content and behind
the scenes footage although pricing
details remain on the schools Patel
mentioned that the official launch will
once will follow once you know despite
this depart across okay go type in
Tucker is this the one that says 50 so
he went on Twitter X to do his show in
exchange for 50 retweets with
Elon what yes that's all he needed in
exchange for 50 retweets with Elan so if
you type in Tucker Carlson x uh 50
retweets retweets that's so that's so
weird that's so like but but it's this
is exactly what I talked about when I
said why would Tucker turn down the $100
million offer we made to him mhm because
50 retweets from Elon is worth more to
him than $100 million think about that
50 retweets is worth more than $100
million offer being made and was it was
it any specific or whenever just I mean
not back to back to back to back to back
or whenever Tucker goes please retweet
this one what do you mean like which
which tweets of Tucker were I have to
show you guys this because you have to
see it you have to see it to understand
what I'm talking about uh with with him
and musk but the idea is now milania is
saying hey maybe this guy would make a
good VP um you know he you know she
would like to see him be a VP and
potential candidate as a VP do can you
see Tucker as a VP Tom do you think that
would be a wise move to have Tucker
Carlson as the VP for Trump absolutely
tell me why well number one this guy is
very well read
and not only that his position
statements and his point of views on the
three key areas that a president really
can impact he can impact the economy
through treasury number one number two
he can uh impact domestic policy through
things that he puts out there like a
Disaster Area recovery things like that
then also on foreign policy who
secretary of state is and the positions
that we take on the two things in
foreign policy defense-oriented position
where you're giving guns to a friend um
or or economics and those are the things
that I think Tucker Carlson really has a
very strong intellect on and he
understands how Washington works so if
if that's the measure of a vice
president understanding how Economic
Policy um and then domestic policy in
general and foreign policy work then the
guy the guy has the the credentials to
be there and he's very visible to the
American americ voters so now let's go
the other way you know you got to pick
somebody who's visible you got to Pi
somebody who's bankable votable
electable and he has all those so if I
look at it on a quantitative basis that
way you know the the old method was hey
you're not very strong in Texas maybe
LBJ could be your vice president
candidate and help you carry Texas that
used to be the way it works it doesn't
really work that way anymore it's all
about the candidate but the vice
president can't be a drag um we all know
who the vice president candidate was for
John McCain and she was a drag on the
ticket you don't want that Dan Quail
even though he proved to be right in
vanity far wrote an article that said
Dan Quail was right about the following
things he was a
drag on on Bush Senor so you can't be a
drag on the ticket you have to be
something and they the last time you've
seen um I think
something well let's go look at Obama
and Biden Biden was the Elder Statesman
that knew his way around Washington so
you can trust that Obama's going to get
good advice that was the pitch that we
were all sold on the selection of uh Joe
Biden and I think Tucker lines up very
well he checks all the boxes he'd be a
ferocious debater and so I think then
you have to think okay one heartbeat
from the presidency okay could he be you
know a president on the order of
reaganesque uh conservatism that is that
has uh been successfully malleable into
the world in which we live today and I
think the answer is yes I think I dude
like imagine having him as Vice he
wouldn't be one of these Kamala do
nothing just by the way don't even know
what what kamla does or where she is
he'd be a phenomenal vice president and
then think about like you said Tom he'd
take the mantle I think because I think
he's a true patriot and then you never
know maybe he'd put like a V or somebody
is his vice president and then that that
line of just true people that care about
this country will keep keep keep keep on
going and I think that that'd be a great
choice I would love I would love I don't
see it guys what I don't see it you
don't see what I don't I don't I think
Tucker is an alpha I don't think he's
trying to take advice from and like
listen any be number two for anybody he
walked into the UFC behind Trump and
looked like a pretty good number two I
just I think Tucker is focused on
building his media company he's never
ran for anything in his life he's never
expressed any interest for running
anything in his life and if I'm Trump I
want someone that's basically saying get
behind me have my back basically do what
Mike Pence did for three years and 364
days okay and just follow my lead and
also I don't see Tucker bringing any
independent or votes that Trump doesn't
already have people that like Tucker
already like Trump it's no one new the
reason that he picked Pence was because
Trump is arguably the least Christian
dude out there on his resume at least so
he needed that nice white Christian
conservative named Mike Pence to get in
line for that Evangelical vote so now
who's going to be on Trump short list I
don't see Tu I don't see Tucker run a
poll and see I see Tucker being a beast
I think on a debate stage versus Kamala
he would run circles around here I just
don't think he's going to carry
particular an article just came out
Trump is reportedly planning a cabinet
from hell for term two this is
intelligence sir Donald Trump is
reportedly consider ing a contentious
roster of candidates for key cabinet
positions in a potential second term
this list include figures like Ohio
Senator JD Vance Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckaby Sanders Arizona's Kerry Lake
South Dakota Governor's Christy gome
Georgia representative margerie Taylor
green as potential vice president
choices wow those are potential Vice
President Van Sanders Kerry Lake gnome
Taylor and Trump has expressed interest
in Tucker Carlson it could R up the
magga base but would run the risk of
upstaging trump at rallies continues
Trump's intent to reward loyalists who
have backed his claims of election fraud
as evident in
his potential cabinet appointments these
appointments May feature Steven Miller
as attorney general or in a role to
related to immigration enforcement
amongst the names in contention for
cabinet positions are Lee zeldon for
defense secretary Richard grenell
for Director of National Intelligence
and Steve Bannon for white house chief
of staff oh my God that'd be crazy but
he I think the Carrie Lake vice
president thing to get the female V too
that would be I mean car Lake would be I
think a great decision I like I like
Chrome I like Sanders a lot you like
Sanders Sarah hucke Sanders oh she's a
beast the problem is you know what like
that the problem with her is she's uh
what not goodlook so I think that's not
a good look us okay I'm just G to look
at her yeah and that's like a good
picture of her somehow Adam oh my God
hold on I'll be under the desk Optics
and how you look actually counts okay
now go to Christy Gom by the way it's
the best picture of Sarah huab Sanders
I've ever freaking seen ever in your
life Christy no see if you can do a side
by side of these two I mean there's no
need at you want to look at that girl
every day or you want to look at that
girl every day
what a I think you know where I vote
what about car Lake SE cells bro would
you not be at car Lake you think Donald
Trump is going to look at Sarah Huckabee
Sanders and be like h i uh not my first
Pi hold on guess what that's not what
I'm into if he's he's loyal to the
people that that love him you can't even
front Sarah Huckabee Sanders was in
those briefings every single day in a in
a jungle with everybody from Jim massa's
loser ass screaming at her every
freaking 2 minutes it was insane it was
insane that she had had his back she
never turn that's your new VP right
there I listen by the way I'm a policy I
don't need to look at her face if she's
looking like the one in the pink right
now she could thank her uh candidacy
choices to oek she looks like she's lost
100 pounds good for her can't fix an
ugly face though I'm sorry this is just
but listen anybody that's a loyal she
she's loyal to Trump and she's about
that policy that's great but I'd rather
have Christy know him save the photo
yeah I can't look at that anymore she
saved the world she saved our economy
too bad she wasn't more attractive yeah
what did I mean you ever see Superwoman
yeah you you are you going call you know
maybe Adam needs to uh they need to do a
part two of the movie Shallow how oh and
they say shallow Adam and Tony Robbins
comes up and next thing you know Adam
shows up and introduces to a girl hey
this is Mary Dam she's hot what the hell
wrong with you is this guy okay Adam
he's like oh my God sexy sex Shadow Adam
we going ad make AO that made that made
Jack Black's career I'm down so make a
phone call to Tony see what he'll do for
you by the way luxury stores are
bursting with unsold stuff okay weird
unsold stuff luxury fashion brands are
grappling this Wall Street Journal story
grappling with an excess of unsold stock
due to slowing
sales after 15% rise in 2022 online
luxury sellers like my Teresa Rich
Vinnie which one you guys have heard of
my Teresa reported a 44% increase in
inventory luxury Brands protective of
their exclusivity have avoided deep
discounts and burning excess inventory
is now banned in the EU burning excess
inventory is banned in the EU they have
focused on opening concessions and
department stores to maintain control
over inventory and pricing off-price
Outlets are becoming popular choice for
luxury Brands representing 133% of
luxury good sales compared to 5% a
decade ago these Outlets provide a way
to clear stock while maintaining brand
perception with value retailers retail
uh bister collection requiring Brands to
offer an average of 35% discount to
secure spot interesting Rob can you go
to the Rolex article I sent you you know
which one I'm talking about with what's
going on with Rolex with watches watch
this if you can zoom in the record Rush
is that the same article the record rush
to buy Rolex or pek Philip is over let
me read that article there in Bloomberg
the biggest ever boom in Swiss luxury
watches is coming to an end for 3 years
the industry enjoyed a surge of renewed
interest that kicked off during the
pandemic when wealthy and cash flush
consumers stuck at home began drooling
over luxury mechanical wrist wear from
Iconic Swiss Brands the UNT turbocharged
demand for time pieces like AP Rolex and
others boosting Swiss watches export to
record sales damn $25 billion 25 billion
Frank which is 28 20 28.5 billion doll
Tom why do you think this is taking
place with these luxury products
especially with the watches uh
well could it be that the so the Boom at
the top of the collector Market there
was no Boom at the top of the collector
Market um I I collect but uh not
voraciously watches great word great
word and the highend of the watch
collection Market hasn't gone away it's
still there and people that had the
money still have the money and they
collect them out of Interest the middle
of the market was turbocharged by cheap
money and the cheap money has been spent
and so now the demand is down for the
luxury items as inflation and other
things with the economy have kind of it
was a spike so that that headline is
actually correct the rush to buy is over
and people rushed in in and then they
rushed out and that's that's what's
happening here um when you take a look
at um any of them there's a lot of them
out there I'm not going to plug one over
the other but you can get them and put
an app on your phone you can basically
see the stock market for collectible
watches the same way you can see the
stock market for artwork or you know
baseball cards trading cards sports
cards and the big push with all that
cheap money has come and gone and so now
the artificial demand pushed the prices
up now all of those buyers have left the
market and the prices are coming back
down you know what the number along with
the unit they're down uh uh secondhand
luxury watch prices are near two-year
low they're down at this point roughly
40% little shy 40% today yeah twoyear
low G what happened two years ago that's
free money free money fake money fake
success that's right where I was going
to go with this so after in 2020 when
the pandemic hit and all the stimulus
checks were coming out everything was
going on there I predicted that the
luxury Brands up out there the Gucci the
Pras the Louis all that were going to
take a massive hit but what ended up
happening they all got richer so in the
middle of the pandemic most people don't
know this guy's not a household named
Bernard alno he's the owner of lvmh
Louis Vuitton moed Hennessy became the
richest man in the world at that time
number two or three okay jumped up he
jumped up he passed Bezos he passed musk
now he's sitting comfortably at number
two elon's B worth a quarter billion
right now by by the way realtime
billionaires list on Forbes Bernardo no
is second place at 197 billion Jeff
bezos's number three at 170 billion the
list goes on but my prediction was that
all these luxury Brands Who the hell's
going to afford all these Brands
unbelievable who's going to pay $5,000
for a purse turns out your average
stupid American who gets a stimulus
check for 3,600 bucks isn't going to put
that into their Roth IRA they're going
to put that on a purse or a trip to
Miami or go somewhere on spring break we
always say this that the moneyy is going
to flow to the top people aren just
going to take this free money and invest
it in their 401K not going to happen
they're going to ball out they're going
to ball till they fall they're going to
try to keep up to the Joneses they're
going to basically try to fake it till
they make it and that's how you have
Bernard Al no the owner of lvm become a
the second or first richest man in the
world because the average person that's
getting these stimulus checks is just
gonna just spend all that M she she's
gonna make me move to Miami I mean it's
like they Beyond faked it right they be
what's that the the consumer Beyond fake
that not only they spend their stimulus
they took their credit card debt from
half a billion from half a trillion
dollars up to a trillion dollars Wells
Fargo said that the next report is
probably going to be knocking on 1.3
trillion and bnpl is what they're using
you know buy now poor later you know
what's going on well play Tom and so uh
they they they didn't just get drunk and
go out and buy things but now they're
tapped out and guess what's happening
now the brands are coming down but but
if you want to see next year's fashion
if you want next year's fashion to be in
your favorite store here we go all we
need to do yeah is have all the looters
come in and steal this year's fashion
the insurance money on PNC will pay the
retailer so they can send it to Louis
Vuitton and refill the stores with next
year's fashion so there there are some
ecosystems in America that kind of you
know can can can help make it right I
only take fashion advice from the bisoc
that's it that's my guy I'll be you
think I'm going to watch GQ or something
stupid like that it's the BISD everyone
knows that oh have you seen his
underwear ridiculous ridic
fitted V thing you think Tom's a BRI
boxers guy you haven't had Chilla
underwear you haven't really Tom but you
would be funny if Tom has like those
hammock silk oh banana hammock banana
hammock oh you know to up the morning
give me my coffee woman yeah
by way the audience right now is having
a great visualization of Tom and a
banana ham no no no if I talk like that
shout out to Louis Vuitton I'm not going
to need underwear I'm going to need a
cup you know give me my coffee woman
give my coffee woman let's talk about
the last fast track to the if you can
pull up what's going on with real estate
commissions if you can pull this up a
lot of guys in the real estate industry
are calling me and they're talking to me
about this and we may we may bring
somebody on board to go a little bit
deeper into this rigged Federal US court
Awards $1.8 billion in Damages after
major realtor firms found guilty of
conspiring to inflate commissions on
home sales and it turns out that it was
only the beginning so if you can go a
little lower so we can read this Rob uh
zoom in a little bit zoom in a little
bit uh a new federal class action
lawsuit was filed in South Carolina
alleging the n and prominent R estate
brokerage firms like Keller Williams
colluded to artificially inflate agent
commission rates increasing cost for
home sellers IND State go a little lower
and the lawsuit file November 6
okay in Missouri case the federal court
awarded $ 1.8 billion in damage which
could be tripled to more than $5.3
billion according to Reuters if the
Realtors are found to have breached us
Anti-Trust law uh what's the deal with
broker commission the lawsuit of
Missouri is now South Carolina and now
South Carolina are all about real estate
broker commissions which typically is
around 5 to 6% of prop property selling
price in the US and it's split 50/50
between buyer agent and sellers agent at
the heart of the complaint is that they
have wrong fully impacted compan okay so
this the number they're trying to get it
to you know how it shows 5 to six% so
let's do a basic number y say somebody
buys a sells a $500,000
house I'm selling my $500,000 house I'm
the homeowner okay you are representing
Tom Tom wants to buy my house you're his
realtor Adam is my realtor I sell the
house there's 6% in commissions let's
just say he gets 3% you get 3% okay I'll
deal with that so three so you're
splitting 30 grand 15 and 15 you're
spitting 30 grand 15 and 15 and let's
just say if he's working at his real
estate firm he gets paid 50% he's making
7500 bucks you're making 7500 bucks I
can with that some are talking the fact
that they want to make that 5 to 6% they
want to turn it into 1 to 2% and allow
me to give a tip what let me explain so
for example that $500,000 house I say
guys I'm only doing 2% okay okay so he
gets 1% you get 1% which is what Grand
so you got 2% on half a million is 10
grand you guys are splitting five grand
you're at 50% commission so you're
making 2500 bucks but I get to choose to
put a tip there so let's just say I say
guys I'll tip you another 100 bucks okay
I'll tip you what a crap can you imagine
what is that what it is that what it is
you kidding me I'm getting calls and
texts from these Realtors talking about
what if this happens what do you think
about this what do you think about some
of them are getting into insur insurance
but a lot of them are calling asking do
you actually think this could happen or
not I I don't know if I'm with it I am
not with them removing that 3 to 6%
they're trying to make that they did
this to the mortgage industry mhm years
ago mortgage industry they had something
on their back end called the
correspondence commission which got were
making a lot of money on the back end
with the correspondence checks that was
being paid out by New Century
Countrywide all this stuff but if it
goes this Direction real EST is going to
take a hit with some of the bigger
players Tom what are your thoughts on
this yourself well commission
adjustments have been happening at the
high end of the market for years yeah at
the high end of the market you know
let's say and this is going to sound
really big to people but a $5 million
house sells and if it's a 6% that's
$300,000 that the seller put out there
now there's real cost in in there but
title insurance and a lot of other
things don't cost $100,000 so now let's
split it
150150 for each each side and then if
that is split say 66% the reloader gets
$100,000 commission to sell the one
house that is a little bit less than 2x
the average income of the average
American so that's pretty big and so
usually what what'll happen at the high
end they'll say okay we'll do a 6%
Commission on the first half million and
we'll do 2% or something thereafter and
then you'll even see sometimes in a
listing saying uh flat 2% commission and
so they're letting the buyer know what
kind of stress is or isn't on the seller
so the adjustment commission has been
going on for a while the the other side
of it is Redfin Zillow and online
realor.com have slowly removed a a lot
of the benefit that your realator gave
you the realator used to do real
research and go through the MLS and
bring you a package of homes to look at
right and then they would say hey Vinnie
you're you're talking about having a
child next year if you're here more than
10 years or when the child will now be
like in third fourth grade this school
district over here is by far the best in
the City Realtors used to provide all
that now they argue that they still do
that but what's happening is people are
coming back wait a minute I get a lot of
research from Zillow I get a lot of
from red fin why should we be paying
this and why should you be
prohibiting the the little home the half
a million doll home from negotiating
because the realators won't they'll
negotiate with somebody selling a $5
million home before you open your mouth
before you get upset we will adjust our
commission to get the big listing the
giant listing but the average homeowner
says you know gosh you know 6% on this
that 30 grand means a lot to me you know
as a seller I'm going to give up $30,000
of basically appreciated equity in my
house when I sell this those are the
people that are in the class action that
are saying you rig this why shouldn't I
find my cousin Sarah who will be willing
to do it for 2% and 2% or something why
shouldn't I be able to do that that's
the root of the suit is them saying nope
screw you it's 6% you can't negotiate it
why well because they work for Keller
Williams they won't let me that's why
they're named I work for Remax they
won't let it it's a standard deal see
right here in your listing contract it's
a standard deal well not if I had a
giant house well it is for your little
one that's the way it goes and that's
what's going on I think we all know that
anytime that you're dealing with you
know High net worth individuals or
anything in the 510 plus million dollar
range um there's going to be some sort
of commission Cuts negotiated if you're
selling a $20 million house you're not
just going to let the advisor or the
real estate agent take their typical
six% fee even in my business if I'm
dealing with a $10 million policy and
the commission is going to be a half a
million do they say hey look man we're
gonna what can we do on this we don't
want to be pigs we don't want to lose
the business we'll cut the Commission in
half of what it comes down to but for
your average case like your average
house these days is worth what
$300,000 with 6% of that okay you're
talking 5 10 grand here how are these
how these agents supposed to basically
work and do this because a lot of these
agents will put in money to market the
property there's no question to put in
all the work it's not exactly easy to do
this so what's going to end up happening
are the high-end guys who are already
making millions of dollars a years
they'll figure it out there's going to
be so many agents who can't even
basically afford to feed their family at
some point so I'd like to see where
basically this comes in because we can
look at the high-end markets those guys
are going to be fine they've already
made their money they've already made
their Mark they work out commissions
they're they're selling $10 million
houses they'll figure it out they'll
reduce their commission to 1 2% they'll
still make their a couple hundred grand
on their commissions all good it's the
guy selling4 million dollar houses the
woman selling a half million doll houses
that they're going to have to basically
come to terms what do you think is a
fair commission for the for the national
average whatever the seller this is my
opinion whatever the seller is willing
to pay for the quality of a realtor to
sell your house good point I think
that's free market let me decide what I
want to pay my guy okay so if I want to
do you know if a guy comes in and he's
got a buyer that's going to buy the
house for a number that I can't get from
another realtor that's newer go for it
okay if if you're actually going to put
in the work I remember one time Tom
remembers this I remember one time I saw
one of my houses in LA and his realtor
was a newer realtor and I did a favor
cuz she was going to the same church she
comes to these multiple appointments
Adam I am furious cuz she has no clue
what the hell she's doing she's never
sold the house bigger than
$600,000 and this going to be her first
ever million doll home she's selling and
you did her a favor you know what I told
her to do do you remember what I told
her to do go back church I said don't
show up when this I said there's only
one way I'm going to continue working
with you when the client shows up I
don't want you here don't show up so the
client shows up and I show the client
the house and I show the client the
details and I agree with the client with
the number and I did tell you take the
commission but I don't want you to be
here cuz you're not helping out at all
wow I sold the house yeah and then we
move to you if there's anybody that
knows the story it's Thomas it's you and
J did you pay
she got the whole commission but guess
what she got overpaid she did not
deserve the commission why did you give
her the because the market is filled
with lazy Realtors lazy Realtors should
not get paid what they get paid but a
working realtor go I don't have a
problem if a working realtor is going to
go make a deal happen and a miracle
happen I'm okay with that anyways okay
podcast came to an end we did couple
hours gang if you're with us on a
Saturday crew I know typically we do it
Tuesdays and Thursdays when we'll do
home team we'll do it again this week
but I wanted to make sure we talk
because we haven't done any podcast for
quite a few days have a phenomenal
weekend we'll do it again next week take
care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye